well speaking of dangerous there's big
news this week about climate change
in a recent study
who said that
who's there
it's me
it's my
bonnet oh hey bonnet
hey i put you on before bed last night
but when i woke up you were nowhere to
be found
that's cause i'm a mischievous little
rascal oh bonnet you're supposed to stay
on my head why should i no one likes
bonnets anymore in fact some people have
trouble with folks wearing bonnets out
in public
oh
bonnet
yep i think they're ashamed of us
because
we're bad hey whoa bonnet you're not bad
and yes there have been a lot of people
who say black women should stop wearing
bonnets in public and now sometimes
places won't allow you in if you're
wearing one but don't you worry about
that did you know that it used to be
illegal in a lot of places for black
people to leave their house without
their hair covered up
whoa
i feel like you're making that up i know
i wish i was but they were mad about us
not covering up our hair and now they're
mad that we are covering it up so we
can't win
why would people do such a thing well my
theory is hundreds of years ago they had
to dehumanize black people in order to
feel okay about enslaving us and a quick
way to do that is to think of us as
dirty and bad and a lot of us never want
to be looked at that way so we try extra
hard to make sure we and every black
person around us looks perfect but the
way we dress isn't the problem judging
black people based on your idea of how
they should look is called
respectability politics and that is the
problem but you don't hurt bonnet
it is
funny you don't hurt
you actually you help
i really help yeah
whether it's making sure my ends don't
break or keeping my sloppy bedtime
hairstyle a secret
i'll never tell you come in handy i do
of course you do i love you bonnet
[Music]
sometimes i have a tough time with my
hair
but he's always there for me it's my
bonnet
it's her bonnet oh that's right
whenever i fall asleep i know my style
is gonna keep with me and my bonnet
and her bonnet
[Music]
some people say they don't like the way
i wear it in the store
and yeah that used to make me feel so
sad but it doesn't anymore
cause if i see in my bonnet makes you
sick
you can eat a big fat
cause i love my body
[Applause]
that's right i do
if my bonnet were a baseball cap you
wouldn't have [ __ ] to say you're just
hating on my bonnet
on your bonnet
you know
black women ain't protected out there
now we can't even protect our hair come
on man it's just about it
i'm just a bonnet that's right you are
so
the next time you see a black woman
wearing a bonnet all on her own i want
you to reach inside swallow your pride
and leave her
alone
you should count yourself lucky you've
got to see her come down off her throne
just her and her bonnets
her and her bonnet
it's just me and my bonnet
[Music]
[Applause]
about it i love you
i love you amber okay so bonnie the next
time anyone gives you any guff you oh oh
no he's gone
she wears her hair and four sloppy
braids at bedtime god damn it
[Music]
you